mexico and i respect mexico i respect
their leaders what they've done to us is
incredible their leaders are so much
smarter so much sharper
and it's incredible in fact that could
be a mexican plane up there they're
getting ready to attack
page hannah back
and i've been to china
and i saw the great wall of china have
you seen that yet
anybody here saying the great wall
anyone you've been to china
are you chinese no korean oh man you
must have been so
jealous that's good
i'm just kidding you guys got the
demilitarized zone that's great
i mean what do you call it what do you
guys got in korea
the dmz right the something something
parallel
45th parallel it's a thin layer of
america
protecting you i'm just kidding
did you like the great wall it was
amazing was it
you know why because it's the largest
man-made object on earth that's what
they said
and she claimed the tour guide that it's
the only man-made object
visible from space i have yet to confirm
that i'm still getting
still getting my space money together
but it was amazing
i thought i personally would make
because i didn't know that
the ancient chinese people actually had
you know mexicans like that
i'm not saying mexicans built that wall
i'm saying chinese build that role keep
mexicans out of jail
that's a very advanced culture
america didn't think of that till five
years ago
oh i was talking about the first mexican
kid we had in our town right so we had
class with the hamsters right going back
to that right the
the man mr mr blackwell's class we had
the hamsters they let you keep the
hamsters after superman got killed no no
that was it i just mean it was that same
time right everybody would get a
different pet
we used to play this game where you
would like somebody would lay down and
you would put a snake on their back
or a fake snake on their back right and
you would play guess if i have a snake
on my back or not right
and people would literally bet uh if
they did or what they were going to
guess
and then sometimes we put this game
where you because they had this one
rabbit in there that was always falling
asleep is like almost
hey you know like uh whatever rabbit
narcolepsy kind of is you know he just
drifts off you know because it's a
rabbit they're not doing much you know
and you would set a rabbit on a pile of
money you try to pull the dollars out
from under them
and uh and without waking them up that
was like the biggest uh thing we used to
do in class before class
but the problem but not the problem with
the thing that happened was this mexican
kid moved in named
nick right and the first thing he ever
said in class the main was uh
in science they also taught you sex ed
right so
like the first day this kid nick was in
there was during the sex ed part
and he stands up and he goes uh where
he goes what does pop that cherry mean
that's what he said
he asked about your teacher like it's
serious he's convinced like who just
popped that cherry mean
and then he uh he ended up banging some
girl like in sixth grade right and
uh and she broke up with him broke his
heart and he
he started like rap music and he wore
this t-shirt that said
nick the rapper that he wrote on it with
a marker right but he only put one p
in it and it said nick the raper on it
the [ __ ] shirt that he wore
and they [ __ ] expelled him they
expelled him
that's racism uh i guess he was mexican
but see mexican didn't play a part and
he was a bad speller and he [ __ ]
was asking stupid questions what does
that cherry mean
the porn star of comedy let him hear it
mr martin moreno
[Applause]
nice no joke
what is this like week five now that
we've been here week five for sure yeah
yeah a month
about him yeah over a month you guys
hanging out here in florida and uh
but he got crazy the other night i don't
know he texts me and he mentioned it
earlier but he uh
he got a little crazy and wound up in
hialeah somewhere at someone's house
and for everybody watching at home
hialeah is no joke it's it gets crazy
over there all right
if you're white and you're driving
through hialeah after one in the morning
even the gps is like
good luck careful
[Applause]
oh yeah it is the east coast version of
east los angeles yes that's
and of course what are people asking you
know when are you gonna shoot the next
one and i've been talking about doing
stuff here in florida for quite some
time and so i'm really excited
and i actually thought i used to think
that uh the cubans were the number one
latinos here in town i come to find out
that puerto ricans are creeping up
[Applause]
puerto ricans you guys are very easy to
identify most latinos you got to listen
to the spanish
puerto ricans i give it up you're easy
to identify because there's always a
flag nearby
puerto ricans love the puerto rican flag
and i know why
i know why because no one's looking for
you
you can be as proud as you are
all day long if you don't know the
puerto rican flag it's very easy to
identify it's red white and blue it has
one big star on it
a triangle and uh it's like the american
flag but tweaked
it's like the cuban flag but backwards
in the colors
yeah you guys love that flag you will
put that flag on anything freaking
bumper sticker hat t-shirts wallets a
baby's born
oh yeah you're definitely the most
advantaged of all the latinos
you know because mexicans were you know
we're loud to an extent
but when we realized that there could be
potential drama
[Music]
but we work hard and i noticed too like
um there's actually a mexican community
here in town i didn't know about
and uh i saw some guys doing
construction and that's when i found out
because
i heard the music playing and it wasn't
like celia cruz or nothing that was
actually freaking you know regular going
you know straight up i was like that's
mexican music and i saw a guy on one of
the scaffoldings and i go you guys are
working over here oh she said or she
senor
i go in this economy you guys are
building another house oh senor these
people have a lot of money
mucho dinero mucho dinero are they rich
very rich how rich senor i'm not even
mexican he pays me to talk like this
[Applause]